What's wrong with people?
Yeah. Ass ass ass naked and also act like
squirrel. They ain't got no edit button.
You can trim that out, right?
Right before the ass part.
Why you ass naked with a baby squirrel, man?
What you doing? All right, hold on, hold on.
Wait a minute. That one plays with animals
that get out in the nude.
He had to release it.
He had to release that.
He had to look at that whole clip and be
like, that's fine. Oh, and I'm going to
upload it. Oh my God, if I could be inside
of the Chipmunks f***ing mind for two
seconds, I'm getting the f*** out of here.
You tell these folks how freaky your freaky
ass is. Watch this.
Playing with us chipmunks all the time and
nobody here to defend us against your naked
bullsh*t. I'm sending this to Alvin.
Simon. Hey, y'all real f***ing tears in my
eyes. I did not expect that said naked ass.
What? What type of freaky sh*t- happening in
the world? People say the baby's mine.
Baby chipmunks are squirrels.
Oh, God. Why are you f***ing ass naked?
With The squirrel in your hand at the
camera. Oh, hope he doesn't jump out at me.
I think you I think you hope.
Oh, God. All right, all right, let's go.
That's it. He had me fooled.
You talking. I thought it was humanitarian.
He's like, you're so cute.
Just be careful, cause you don't want him to
jump out. He was about to put the squirrel
in his ass on camera, f***ing literally
crying right now. Oh, God.
Oh, God.
Oh, God. All right.
Oh. All right. Are you ready?
Come on. All right.
I'm sorry, man, you can't do it like that.
Hell, just get his attention.
I'm f***ing sorry. Here we go.
All right, listen, if you've made it this
far, that means that you're.
You're against squirrels going and f***ing
people's asses just like I am.
Okay, you better finish what you started.